il y fait c'est normal c'est difficile
de ne pas s'en souvenir mais des
cauchemars je n'en ai pas je n'ai pas
laissé les choses négatives m'influencer
à l'époque des milliers de cubains
partait pour les états unis dans des
embarcations de fortune
une bonne moitié périssé en mer eliane
sa mère et 11 autres personnes sont pris
dans une tempête dans le détroit de
floride
il n'y a que trois survivants
le 25 novembre 1999 le petit elian qui
n'a pas encore six ans est retrouvée
seule à la dérive sur une chambre à air
par des pêcheurs de floride
seize ans plus tard elian gonzalez a du
mal à oublier le drame qui a coûté la
vie à sa mère a ému fasciné la planète
et a peut être changé l'histoire du
monde
je me souviens quand l'embarcation a
chaviré
quand je me suis retrouvé dans la mer
sur la bouée avec ma mère elle me
recouvrait et je m'endormais j'étais à
moitié déshydraté et j'aime éveillé de
temps en temps et à un moment donné j'ai
ouvert les yeux et je me suis retrouvé
seul
tout le reste le sauvetage de transfert
à l'hôpital je ne me souviens de rien
la légende veut que des dauphins les
protéger des requins
après ces longues heures de dérive en
mer il est recueilli par sa famille à
miami des oncles des cousins
le père des lianes divorcé de sa mère
ignorait tout de leur départ il découvre
vite que son fils était vivant
au début il a toujours été question de
me rendre mon fils tout était normal
ma famille a fait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour récupérer l'enfant et veiller sur
lui
c'est après que tout s'est compliqué les
groupes anticastristes de miami s'empare
de la fère et s'oppose fermement au
retour du petit vers son père à cuba le
petit elian devient un otage politique
un enjeu de la guerre froide entre cuba
et les etats unis c'est là que l'argent
le commerce la politique contre cuba
entre en scène licences ont servi comme
d'un trophée
ils ont vu comment ils pouvaient
profiter de lui et c'est comme ça que
tout a commencé à la télévision en
anglais le petit elian fait une
déclaration choc
il dit qu'il veut rester aux états unis
qu'il ne veut pas retourner à cuba
maintenant que je suis grand je revois
les images et je me dis mais sur vous
étiez tellement stupide tobio comment un
enfant qui a passé moins trois mois aux
etats-unis qui n'a même pas six ans
aurait pu apprendre l'anglais aussi
rapidement et de temps je répétais ce
qu'on me disait la sphère eliane tient
en haleine la presse du monde entier
juan miguel demande de l'aide ou
ministre cubain des affaires étrangères
pour récupérer son fils c'est fidel
castro qui lui répond dans quatre ans le
2 décembre le commandant fidel castro me
chercher vers 11 heures du soir ou
minuit j'arrive à son bureau où nous
avons parlé jusqu'au matin gouard est
tous les maux communs serre notamment
concernant d'abord manière et damien pas
son ballon ballon
mais aussi avait connu un cas semblable
au mien précisément avec son fils
fidelito qui avait le même à chillan
quand sa mère a emmené aux états unis il
a dû faire la même chose que moi pour le
faire revenir à cuba fidel castro ont
fait une cause personnelle derrière lui
la tous les cubains l'opinion publique
américaine aussi penche nettement pour
le retour des lianes vers son père le
gouvernement clinton est d'accord et
finalement les tribunaux américains leur
donnent raison et chez eux
eliane est enlevée de force à sa famille
de bigamie ces images ont bouleversé le
monde entier il ya aussi bien sûr mon
manteau web d'abord ça a été un choc de
voir arriver ces personnes ils m'ont
sorti du placard nous sommes tombés et
quand je suis arrivé à cuba
j'avais encore des marques de la chute
mais c'étaient des professionnels avec
leur stratégie militaire
l'opération s'est déroulée de manière
très professionnelle
djouba ils ont commencé à parler
espagnol et ils m'ont dit nous sommes
des amis de ton papa et nous allons le
retrouver s'il ya qu ils me l'ont passé
au téléphone et ça m'a soulagé
je crois que si j'ai réussi à éviter les
séquelles et surmonter tout ça le plus
vite possible c'est grâce au
professionnalisme de ces personnes son
père juan miguel n'attendait à miami où
on lui avait offert de l'argent s'il ne
retournez pas à cuba fidel castro
lui-même lui avait donné l'option de
rester aux états unis avec toute sa
famille ici le désirez ils étaient prêts
à me laisser partir il me l'a répété
plusieurs fois et il a tout fait pour
que je puisse m'en aller si je le
voulais sans aucun problème
les gonzalez considère fidel castro
comme un membre de la famille comme un
grand père il se voit souvent
ceci dit pas de privilège particulier la
famille vit dans une maison confortable
mais modeste dans sa ville d'origine
cardenas et juan miguel est toujours
barman dans un complexe hôtelier de
varadero
il y en a 23 ans il termine son cours
d'ingénieur industriel il va exercer sa
profession dans l'armée quinze ans plus
tard eliane et son père voudrait
profiter d'ouverture entre les deux pays
car malgré tout ils ont gardé de bons
amis américains en floride qu'ils
aimeraient rover ce sont des gens que je
voudrais remercier parce que nous sommes
devenus des amis
ce sont des gens qui nous ont tendu la
main et qui nous ont donné la
possibilité de les connaître à fond
parce que ceux qui l'ont vu en nous
c'est une famille qui voulait tout
simplement que le père et le fils soient
réunies malgré son statut de héros son
père a tout fait pour le protéger le
plus possible de la presse aujourd'hui
adultes ils acceptent avec réticence de
parler de rappeler des moments
douloureux en s'efforçant de les
maîtriser quelque chose qui forge le
caractère
ce sont des expériences même si j'aurais
voulu que rien de tout cela m'arrive
d'abord de perdre ma mère
ensuite parce que je ne voulais pour
rien au monde devenir célèbre cause de
ça
de tout